bon écoute alors ce qu'on va faire en
revanche axelle red
c'est un anti portrait chinois alors
êtes vous connaissez le ventre et
chinois si vous étiez une fleur je serai
remis aux autistes
car là c'est l'anti portrait chinois si
vous étiez une maladie je serai un rhume
une drogue
je serai la cocaïne
parce que j'ai fait une chanson sur mon
album qui s'appelle blanche neige oui
cette relance neige et j'ai comparé la
cocaïne à une femme par lequel on est
obsédé à la sauce rivières on serait
obsédé par moi ouais si vous étiez un
bruit si vous étiez une faute de goût je
serai moi même pas pourquoi et je sais
pas j'étais ma soeur m'a toujours dit
que j'avais jamais mauvais goût parce
que je porte les choses qu'ont les gens
qu'on prenne part au corps alors me
disant attendre un peu de temps et moi
je vais vous dire un truc qui te prendre
un pain de philippe van tran sortant je
trouve de plus en plus sexy mois se
confirme
là ce soir reste bouche bée
on a encore une inconnue accélérait dès
l'été elle était bébé mais là elle
devient femme quoi vraiment bien si vous
y étiez
une façon de mourir mourir de rire
ouais une insulte une allergie
elle lit une allergie un mieux lotis si
vous étiez une question qui vous ferait
quitter ce plateau ce serait quelques
questions j'étais folie de rester
c'était arnaud j'aurais dit que j'allais
faire
je dois être éclairé c'est normal en
même temps est ce qu'il boit il puise
souvent si vous étiez une arme le regard
critique à une perversion sexuelle
containers si vous étiez une teinture
rater si vous regarde quand tu auras que
à axelle red
si vous étiez une blague belge vous
savez ce qui m'ennuie les français c'est
que j'aime pas raconter les blagues au
fond très parce que d'habitude il faudra
compter deux fois ci c'est une mauvaise
critique ce qui me ferait le corps le
plus mal c'est de dire qu'il n'ya pas de
mélodie
si vous étiez un surnom qui fâchent
j'aimerais fait à ta place
moi j'aurai un pour vous oui le guen le
signe que ce soit et je me fâche et
l'album
monsieur